bon ben on inverse les rôles c'est le
gage que j'avais accepté un allez viens
chine
[Applaudissements]
c'est marrant je me sens mieux payés
alors qu'ils regardaient ce rebond soir
soit reconnaissait le principe on va
faire l'interview psy ah ouais c'est la
vub si on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
en la bouche pendant le jean galle
[Applaudissements]
tu connais des questions alors su quand
on refait le djing alors à lui
maintenant non je vais bouger je suis
baffie mois on leur fait en la bouche
pendant le qinghai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est reposant mais là où tu es très con
c'est que je dirais pour la prochaine
république j'ai pas pensé oui tu
prendras cas les oliviers c'est con
comme un communiqué alors est ce que tu
es shadow ouais j'aime bien faire mal
j'aime bien passer le bout des seins
maso
ouais temps en temps j'aime bien me
faire passer le bout des seins
claustro claustro non pas du tout au
contraire j'adore être pas de salle ont
enfermé que lazard être enfermé tous à
jouer mythos nitoo bah oui je me prends
pour thierry ardisson donc sunnito
schizo schizo bah oui je suis quatre
personnages à la fois je suis un ami
avait écrit que j'étais à la fois que je
voulais être daniel filipacchi patrick
sabatier paul morand et finalement
j'étais un peu des trois aujourd'hui
chez un peu plus thierry ardisson
parano de moins en moins de parano mais
c'est vrai pendant des années je pensais
que tout le monde disait du mal de moi
puis un jour la profession fait décerner
un 7 d'or est donc depuis je sais que
tout le monde adore les spas jean-luc
exo nouveau pardon et ouais j'aime bien
me balader à poil et mes enfants me le
reproche de la dispo thouars tué
mes enfants me laurence roche
agglo
travelo non je me suis habillé une fois
ans fille d'un bain de minuit aux bains
douches et ça n'allait pas non non
fétiche aux as j'aime bien oui j'aime
bien les petits des petits objets des
petits souvenirs les pieds géronto
gérons tout pas du tout alors c'est
marrant je suis plutôt l inverse la pédo
zone non non non je pourrais pas faire
l'amour avec mon cheval parce qu'il ya
une trop grosse [ __ ]
ragot pardon ragots est-ce que je suis
radio à j'adore les ragots et ce à tous
les ragots sur la profession safem le
dernier à qui marche le mieux en ce
moment c'est le restaurant de jean luc
delarue qui s'appelle la redevance parce
que c'est vous qui l'avez payé est ce
que tu es sanglots sanglots ouais bah je
suis sanglots quand je vais voir le film
de joe louis et bacri le goût des autres
ou qu'on tombe dans nos sept d'or choix
ses sanglots obispo
non non honnêtement je suis pas obispo
dans sage et plus en plus même si je
devenais obispo je me ferais attention
masse turbo de moins en moins mais fois
parce que plus tu es célèbre boîte
trabzon te masturber
est ce que tu es populo bachy populo moi
je viens du peuple donc évidemment j'ai
aucun mépris pour le peuple puisque j'en
viens on va le faire
on peut
[Applaudissements]
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu